en plein de confinement la crainte d'une
résurgence de l'épidémie en italie deux
nouveaux foyers de couronnes à virus ont
été déclarés ces derniers jours à rome
dans un hôpital et dans un immeuble
squatté qui a été mise en quarantaine au
total plus d'une centaine de personnes
seraient contaminées pour cinq décès
selon les autorités sanitaires la
crainte d'un rebond d'épidémie au moment
où le premier ministre italien est
entendu par la justice sur sa gestion de
la crise sanitaire
elle a déjà fait plus de trente quatre
mille morts je vous ai des comptes et
qui assure n'avoir rien à se reprocher
françois de sales et lambert et walid
ben ali l'audition aura duré trois
heures face avec giuseppe compter la
procureure de bergame maria cristina
routard venu spécialement de lombardie
aujourd'hui nous avons entendu les
personnes impliquées dans le processus à
savoir le premier ministre le ministre
de la santé et le ministre de
l'intérieur les auditions se sont
déroulées avec implication est dans une
atmosphère de collaboration totale et
des maxima collabos de cerner cet
automne à aller lors de cette audition
beaucoup de questions sont les retards
dans la création d'une zone rouge en
lombardie
quand la région ont été touchés de plein
fouet par le cos vide 19 deux localités
sont concernés nesme bros et alsano
lombardo dès la fin du mois de février
le gouvernement italien décidé de
confiner une dizaine de municipalités
dans cette partie du nord du pays
mais passer de communes malgré les mises
en garde des experts
après de nouvelles consultations
giuseppe qu'on finit par signer un
décret un mois plus tard qui place huit
amis en zone rouge
et depuis les familles des victimes ont
déposé une cinquantaine de plaintes
contre x
il s'agit de la première étape nous
avons réalisé concrètement ce qui
jusqu'à aujourd'hui était limité à
internet
tout a commencé avec un groupe facebook
que j'ai créé avec mon père le 22 mars
pour voir s'il y avait d'autres
personnes qui voulaient raconter leur
histoire qui à leurs yeux comportait des
zones d'ombré nous voulons la vérité
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
recevoir justice c'est lui qui a fait
une erreur il est juste qu'il paye pour
cela aujourd'hui encore les autorités
lombarde et le gouvernement comptait se
rejettent les responsabilités dans la
gestion de cette crise avant son
audition le président du conseil s'est
montré plus que sera je le répète mon
attitude est tout à fait calme non pas
comme un signe d'arrogance ou d'attitude
présomptueuse mais je suis quelqu'un qui
a agi en suivant la science et la
conscience chaque fois que j'ai pris une
décision
parfois même très difficile parce que
derrière tout cela il y a beaucoup de
morts et beaucoup de personnes qui ont
souffert mais j'ai la conscience
tranquille et après avoir travaillé avec
les autres ministres et des personnes
compétentes
des experts nous avons essayé de faire
tout ce qui était possible pour sauver
notre nation
la lombardie reste la région d'italie la
plus touchée par le cos vie 19 avec plus
de 16 mille morts
sur les 34 mille que compte le pays